although I did not appear in a picture
last year I did direct one Kotch which
thank god was nominated for four awards
tonight direction that was that's very
nice thank you direction was not one of
them and we're gonna have a little talk
about that later however to present the
award for the best achievement in
directing an actress who makes any
directors job easier miss Natalie Wood
and one of the few directors whose name
will always rank with that of any star
mr. Frank Capra
I've got it right here nightly okay did
you ever get an itch to become a film
director neither well I could if I
wanted to you know though is Webber Ida
Lupino Dorrit Dorothy Osmond or they all
did it so why not me why not I know
you'd add something well what's the
secret of directing secretly directly
well you got a good writer and a good
producer get some fine actors to the top
cameraman I set the set decorator and I
know feel matter a big crew you got a
thing with all that creative talent who
needs a director out shout that's read
the nominees Frank you're a believer in
one man one film and I'd like to know if
you really think it's possible for one
man to do all the jobs all the creative
work isn't is it possibly never been
done no I'd never possible but but it
has been done it been done once
guess who by whom Charlie Chaplin yes
Charlie Chaplin he did the whole thing
let's get on with it for that word tell
me alright let's do it
those men nominated this year for the
best achievement in directing Peter
Bogdanovich for the last picture show
BBS productions Columbia William
Friedkin for the French Connection
D'Antoni productions 20th Century Fox
Norman Jewison for the Fiddler on the
Roof
Mary's Cottier productions United
Artists Stanley Kubrick for a Clockwork
Orange a Hawks films limited production
Warner Brothers and John's messenger for
Sunday Bloody Sunday a Joseph Yanni
production United Artists and here my
dear it is Twitter no Frank I I know
that we always alternate between
presenters but I truly believe the
winner would rather hear it from you
that's enough okay
I'm very nervous doing this the winner
is William Friedkin
this is a tremendous honor and I'm very
proud to accept it I'm proud to of the
people that helped me to make the French
Connection the people of 20th Century
Fox the entire cast and crew especially
Roy Scheider and Gene Hackman for their
fine performances Jerry Greenberg for
his cutting Owen Reisman for his
photography but most of all I would like
to thank the man who made it all
possible not only made it possible for
the picture to be made but for me to
direct it I owe it all to him his name
is Phil D'Antoni
thank you very much ladies and gentlemen